[Musik]
hallo herr zwicker und so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz schnelles nudel
rezept pasta rezepte liebt er alle und
weil bei uns gerade im garten salbei ist
sehr gut wächst und wir richtig viel
salbei haben gibt's salbei pasta wenige
zutaten schnelle zubereitung deswegen
zeige ich euch direkt die zutaten ich
nehme dafür eine packung spaghetti
pinienkerne etwas knoblauch olivenöl
ganz viel salbei aus dem garten
cocktailtomaten sind etwa 200 gramm 100
gramm getrocknete tomaten die waren in
öl eingelegt parmesan natürlich
zitronensaft zum abschmecken und salz
und pfeffer was jetzt zuerst tun könnt
also wenn ihr induktionskochfeld habt
dann geht es im wasser kochen immer ganz
schnell falls ihr noch so eine
herkömmliche ceran platte habt dann
jetzt bittet das nudelwasser einschalten
muss man dazu sagen ich vergesse immer
denn bei uns geht es halt echt sehr
schnell ich kann dann aber trotzdem
schon mal hier auch eine pfanne erhitzen
denn wenn jetzt so ein bisschen parallel
kocht also praktisch die nudeln gekocht
und in einem separaten britta alles
andere dann sei da echt innerhalb von
zehn minuten fertig dazu wirklich zehn
minuten ich nehme jetzt hier nämlich
einfach mein knoblauch olivenöl
falls ihr das nicht habt einfach ein
normales olivenöl nehmen und gerne bitte
knoblauch dazugeben und ich finde es
jetzt ganz wichtig dass die
salbeiblätter einfach schön knusprig
werden und deswegen so ein bisschen mehr
olivenöl ist auch so ein leckeres rezept
was ihr auch mal kalt essen können wenn
es einfach euch zu warm ist auch jetzt
gerade wenn so sommer ist was warmes zu
essen dann macht ihr einfach nudelsalat
draußen ist einfach schön kalt und es
ist einfach sehr erfrischend und dem
salbei habe ich jetzt hier bereits
gewaschen und so ein bisschen trocken
getupft das ist auch wichtig damit
kleidet anfängt zu spritzen
aber ich glaube ich gebe da
schöne kleine platte rein
haben wasser rein tropfen lassen ja
ansonsten gerne hier nochmal ein
bisschen trocken
[Musik]
das schönste tier
heißt auch nicht zu hoch einstellen
damit sie nicht verbrennen
[Musik]
live berichtet und wenn die so ein
bisschen knusprig sind einfach zur seite
schieben und gerne aus der pfanne nehmen
damit der sage nach verbrennt als jetzt
schon wissen darauf acht er soll zwar
knusprig sein aber eben auch nicht
verbrennen weil dann schmeckt eben auch
nicht mehr
ihr seht auch da jetzt wirklich nun
ordentliches punkt selber hier aber das
passt doch so ganz gut versteckt hat
oder
was ihr ausscheiden dazu passen heute
werden solche daniel und ich hab's aber
in kombi mit kürbis gegessen im herbst
auf rot dann werde ich jetzt gleich
schon mal das nudelwasser salzen und die
nudeln auch schon mal rein geben wir
brauchen ungefähr 10 11 minuten das
heißt bis dahin will ich dann auch
gleichzeitig
dann alle salbeiblätter
alle salbeiblätter rausnehmen damit er
wirklich auch nichts verbrennen kann
jetzt kommen die pinienkerne rein und
werde ein bisschen gerostet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier einfach darauf achten dass die auch
nicht verbrennen also nicht zu hoch
erhitzen schön bei niedriger stufe oder
bei mittlerer stufe dann kann ich jetzt
hier die cocktail tomaten halbieren und
die getrockneten in öl gelegten tomaten
noch ein bisschen klein schneiden und
ich nehme immer gern die in öl gelegten
oder so soft tomaten damit die einfach
nicht so hart und fest sind wie kann man
da einen schönen tag und die muss man
vorher nicht einweichen denn es gibt oft
getrocknete tomaten die einfach so
trocken sind dass man sie wirklich mit
kochendem wasser übergießen muss und die
finde ich nicht so gut
die tomaten gibt ja dann hier direkt
rein
ich hab es dann auch zum ablöschen
[Musik]
und immer wenn ich getrocknete tomaten
verwendet dann verzichte ich sogar ganz
oft auch fleisch weil es für mich
einfach sehr witzig ist und ich bin dann
braucht man auch keine fleisch-
komponente mehr dabei das heißt ihr
könnt also immer schön vegetarisch oder
sogar vegan zu bereiten
[Musik]
und jetzt gar nicht so lange einkochen
die tomaten sollen wenn ich schön frisch
bleiben und dann kann man das hier auf
niedrigster stufe stellen dass nichts
verbremst und ich kann theoretisch
auf die noten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bis titel wasser habe ich jetzt noch auf
und den rest kann man wegschütten
dann die nudeln dazu
und mit bisschen salz pfeffer und
zitronensaft abschmecken
und jetzt der salbei wieder dazu und
verzierte fünf schönen frank ide ist
es gut unterheben
[Musik]
ich fertig ist mein gericht und ich muss
sagen ich probiere ich jetzt einfach
selber
denn das ist ein schnelles rezept und
das könnt ihr innerhalb von zehn minuten
einfach machen und
vielleicht lasse ich noch meine ganze
liebe kamera vor probieren
gibt ich geb dir noch so ein quatsch wie
salbei blatt darauf
so und ob
marge erwarte ich machte sonntags löffel
[Musik]
ich habe auch mal gelernt dass man als
italiener kein löffeln im beim spaghetti
auf rolle des rollt man sich so am
tellerrand auf
[Musik]
gut jetzt haben wir wieder vor
sollen wir so lange werbung einblenden
[Musik]
ich mag es einfach vor der kamera zu
essen aber das rezept sollte sie auf
jeden fall nachmachen zehn minuten
zubereitungszeit sofort fertig wir
richten uns auch gleich am tisch an und
freuen uns alle auf ein gemeinsames
mittagessen schreibt mir doch gerne mal
welche schnellen rezepte euch noch gerne
oder euch noch gefallen würden was ihr
euch für variationen wünscht dann mache
ich das weniger sagt mach mer so
schnelle rezepte mache ich das sehr
gerne und noch ein tipp falls die nudeln
jetzt so im zwei drei minuten mag leben
sollten denn ich will dir halt ohne
überschritten mit zu viel olivenöl könnt
ihr immer gerne das nudelwasser aufheben
und am tisch einfach und biss mir
darüber gießen dann lösen sie sich
wieder voneinander deswegen habe ich das
immer gerne so ein bisschen also macht
gut bis zum nächsten mal die rezepte
findet ihr auf der leeze blog de oder in
meiner app da könnt ihr euch auch immer
ganz gerne einkaufsliste erstellen
schnelle rezepte suchen vegetarische
oder auch fleisch rezepte oder süßes
schaut einfach ganz vorbei bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]